hey guys this is video master Costa
Luigi here for chess calm and today I'm
going to be doing a new series and the
point of this series is just going to be
to give players of intermediate level
maybe 1200 through 1800 some basic
calculation tips and how to improve your
calculation specifically when you're
looking for a forced win or some kind of
forcing winning continuation basically
this is going to improve your tactical
ability and I'm hoping to give you guys
some insight into the thought process of
how to find tactical solutions to
problems and how to finish the game in
the most effective way and give you guys
some useful tips on how to improve your
calculation improve your thought process
make things go a little bit easier and
smoother when you're looking for
solutions so the position you have in
front of you right now is from one of my
own games and it's black to play and win
so if you want to try and solve it we
definitely recommend that the best way
to get better at something is to try and
fail and then get better because you
learn by trying right so if you want to
pause the video and try and solve this
problem let's block the play and win I
would definitely recommend to do that so
otherwise we're going to move on in the
game I was pretty much only looking for
a way to save the game to draw because
I've been defending the whole game and I
had to play out this long in game and
looks like why it was just about ready
to win by attacking my rook and getting
ready to Queen there pawn and I was just
hoping to find a way to save the game
using d3 pawn is counter play so I went
for the pretty obvious move d2 and the
point of this move of course is that if
white takes the pawn then I can take
their opponent the game is drawn this is
what happened in the game
the main point of the move I played was
that if white takes my rook here I can
give bishop d4 check blocking the rook
from controlling the d1 square and I
queen my pawn next end well in this case
black wins
so after d2
why it was forced to take on d2 I took
on h7 and we drew the game pretty
quickly but the right move here was
actually the move rook takes h7 in order
to find this move you basically just
have to use a very basic principle when
calculating which is reversing the order
of moves and what that means is a lot of
times if you're trying to figure out
some combination there's usually certain
tactical elements in this case the key
tactical point you have to see you is
that black has this resource at some
point Bishop d4 check blocking the rook
from the D file and being able to Queen
our pawn so the point here is that if
white takes the rook we play d2 the only
way y can try and stop this pawn is to
play rook d7 and now Bishop d4 check and
black wins the game we queen on the next
move what's the main difference here
well the difference is that our pawn
after rook takes h7 is still on d3 so
white can't play rook takes d3 we can
just take it and be up a rook so because
of that this is a winning solution for
black because well white has to do
something like Rik d8 and then we simply
have this extra pawn here in fact right
away black has bishop d4 check King F 1
and rook H 1 mate so basically after
rook takes h7 white more or less has to
resign is it hard to find a move like
this I think it's pretty difficult if
you're not looking for a winning
continuation which is I think probably
the main thing that keeps players from
finding winning moves in their games is
that you're not always looking for some
kind of tactic when you're playing a
game no one tells you oh by the way it's
black to play and win you can only make
your own evaluation of the position and
then decide you know if you have some
kind of combination or winning tactic to
win the game but your radar isn't always
perfect you know it's not like you
always know when you have a winning
combination and in this case since I was
defending this long end game you know I
was only looking for ways to save the
game I had no idea I had a chance to win
with rook takes h7 and of course after
Rick takes h7 Rick takes h7 d to rook d7
this was the whole point is that you
know we reversed the order of
moves instead of pushing d2 first you
know we force White's roca way and then
back having them lose time in after
Bishop d4 check it's also important to
recognize that after Rick takes d4 check
King takes d4 you know white Snider King
have no way of stopping this pawn and
black wins so in our second position
here it's white to play and win so if
you want to pause the video and try to
find the winning continuation without
any hints then now is the time to do
that but otherwise we'll move on this is
also taken from one of my older games
and well basically white has sacrificed
a couple of pawns three to be exact for
some initiative you know obviously we
have this open H file we have this
active Knight and blacks pieces seem
pretty poorly placed like this Knight
and rook are out of the game the Queen
seems tactically suspect and of course
the King here is quite vulnerable but in
order to finish off the game you do have
to show some finesse and some tactical
ability and there's actually several
wins here I mean a move like 9 h6 check
you know takes rook takes would
definitely lead to a win you know Y can
play Knight takes e4 and some point
we're going to bring our Queen here get
rid of this Knight and play Bishop e5
and you know the game will be over right
so I can't really cover everything
because I'm sure there was more than one
win here Knight takes G 7 was probably
like I'm almost positive this was
winning - King takes and Knight takes e4
basically anything that brings our
pieces closer to blacks King will likely
be a winning solution ok maybe you know
ricocheted and black can survive but the
point is that I did want you guys to
find the most powerful and effective way
to finish the game and that was the move
Knight d5 and this is what I played so
the point of this move is that you know
we're threatening Knight take c7 with a
checkmate and we're basically removing
this defender the f6 Knight from blacks
King side if you study this position for
a couple of minutes you'll realize that
this Knight is you know the most
important defender because it's
defending this h5 square like I said
before you know if the Queen can get to
h5 the game is basically over
and 95 comes with two pretty strong
threats the first is to take on e7 with
meit and the second is to take on f6 so
black has no choice but to play Knight
takes d5 now I played 19th g7 which is
good enough because I'm attacking the
Queen
Black is pretty much forced to take the
knight after King takes g7 Queen h5 it
was basically mate in a few moves
but even stronger would have been just
to play Queen h5 right away and black
doesn't really have a good answer to
Queen h7 followed by a checkmate so I
give f6 here and nice mate is queen h7
check King f7 Knight h6 check King g6 is
force and Queen a5 mate for example so
the reason I wanted to show you guys
this problem is that a lot of times if
you're looking for this knockout blow
you know you really have to dig deep
into the kind of the essence of the
position try to figure out what's really
preventing your opponent's position from
collapsing immediately in this case it
was the knight defending this important
square h5 and you know h7 so 95 pretty
much calls for itself and Queen h5 was
just winning immediately I also wanted
to point out here that you know the move
Bishop e5 in the same vein of just
removing this defender would have been
equally strong and and white even has
this threat of like Knight takes g7 and
Queen h5 taking advantage of this pin
followed by mate so you know if you got
to this position and you found something
that looks pretty convincing it likely
was winning but I did want to show you
guys the absolute strongest when you
know the most principle of Knight d5
also bringing our last piece into the
attack and really really putting the
nail in Black's coffin here thanks a lot
for listening and I'll see you around on
chess calm